In real estate, there
is a famous saying
that the most important thing
is location, location, location.
In this recitation, we will be
looking at regression trees,
and applying them
to data related
to house prices and locations.
Boston is the capital of the
state of Massachusetts, USA.
It was first settled in 1630,
and in the greater Boston area
there are about
5 million people.
The area features some
of the highest population
densities in America.
Here is a shot of
Boston from above.
In the middle of the picture,
we have the Charles River.
I'm talking to you
from my office at MIT.
My office is here.
This is MIT here.
MIT lies in the
city of Cambridge,
which is north of the river,
and south over the river
there is Boston City, itself.
In this recitation, we will
be talking about Boston
in a sense of the
greater Boston area.
However, if we look at the
housing in Boston right now,
we can see that
it is very dense.
Over the greater Boston area,
the nature of the housing
varies widely.
This data comes from a paper,
"Hedonic Housing Prices
and the Demand for
Clean Air," which
has been cited more
than 1,000 times.
This paper was written on a
relationship between house
prices and clean air
in the late 1970s
by David Harrison of
Harvard and Daniel Rubinfeld
of the University of Michigan.
The data set is widely
used to evaluate algorithms
of a nature we
discussed in this class.
Now, in the lecture,
we will mostly
discuss classification
trees with the output
as a factor or a category.
Trees can also be used
for regression tasks.
The output at each
leaf of a tree
is no longer a
category, but a number.
Just like classification trees,
regression trees can capture
nonlinearities that
linear regression can't.
So what does that mean?
Well, with classification trees
we report the average outcome
at each leaf of our tree.
For example, if the
outcome is true 15 times,
and false 5 times, the value
at that leaf of a tree would be
15/(15+5)=0.75.
Now, if we use the
default threshold of 0.5,
we would say the value
at this leaf is true.
With regression trees, we now
have continuous variables.
So instead of-- we
report the average
of the values at that leaf.
So suppose we had the
values 3, 4, and 5
at one of the
leaves of our trees.
Well, we just take the average
of these numbers, which is 4,
and that is what we report.
That might be a bit confusing
so let's look at a picture.
Here is some fake data
that I made up in R.
We see x on the x-axis
and y on the y-axis.
y is our variable we are
trying to predict using x.
So if we fit a linear
regression to this data set,
we obtain the following line.
As you can see,
linear regression
does not do very well
on this data set.
However, we can
notice that the data
lies in three different groups.
If we draw these lines here, we
see x is either less than 10,
between 10 and 20,
or greater then 20,
and there is very different
behavior in each group.
Regression trees can fit
that kind of thing exactly.
So the splits would be x is
less than or equal to 10,
take the average
of those values.
x is between 10 and 20, take
the average of those values.
x is between 20 and 30, take
We see that regression trees
can fit some kinds of data
very well that linear
regression completely fails on.
Of course, in reality nothing
is ever so nice and simple,
but it gives us some
idea why we might
be interested in
regression trees.
So in this recitation,
we will explore
the data set with
the aid of trees.
We will compare
linear regression
with regression trees.
We will discuss what the cp
parameter means that we brought
up when we did cross-validation
in the lecture,
and we will apply
cross-validation
to regression trees.